we are the only entertainment show that
had chance to sit down with the cast yes
listen
we knew that Daniel Craig will be back
but today we learned that he will face
off against Oscar winner Robin Malick in
the new movie but will bond 25 really be
Daniel Craig's last all right Daniel
this is supposedly the last bond or is
it the last bomb what would it take to
bring you back this is gonna be my last
one I think someone else should have a
go now filming starts Sunday here on the
island and most of the bond team came
for the announcement the one person
missing the villainous Rami Malek he was
in New York shooting the final season of
mr. robot they've done such a good job
about altering my schedule so I could
leave New York to go shoot in London and
in a month how'd you keep the secret it
was tricky it was a process because I
heard that I was being considered for
this but I tried to lower my
expectations and and tell myself this
was probably not gonna happen but I'm a
fighter and I've always thought there's
a possibility let's try to make it
happen
Romi's just we've got him right at the
moment when his careers just gone
stratospheric
[Music]
last we saw Romney he was picking up an
Oscar for Bohemian Rhapsody there's been
a heck of a year and now you'll and bond
I don't think it gets but much better
than this another dream job and you know
an historic role and one of the greatest
franchises ever you are joining a long
line of great villains how will this one
be different I hope I come up with
something that is gonna shock people and
somehow make him relatable
Rami joins returning cast members
including M ray Fiennes Moneypenny Naomi
Harris
Q Ben Whishaw as well as other newbies
including new Bond girls on at the armas
and leshawna lynch your family is from
jamaica
what's it like being here it's fabulous
it's just very rare that your culture
and your work align now filming on the
newly constructed sets here in Jamaica
is sort of a homecoming because the
first Bond film dr. no was filmed in and
around this area will we get the ursula
shot walking out of the wall okay
[Music]
[Applause]